[Music]
thank you
can hate Jake Paul you know I don't I
don't like the guy but I won't shy away
from talking about like his his
um story as a fighter it's like I like
fighting it's like I don't have an issue
acknowledging like yeah he's getting
better he he's on track to be good I'm
curious to see where he lands the people
that go maybe just he's just beating up
old guys for money okay
dude half you dudes have had private
conversation with your boys where you're
like how much to suck a dick and some of
you have been like are [ __ ] I suck a
dick for 100 grand right now so you you
beat the [ __ ] out of an old guy for like
five mil okay I don't want to hear it
there's definitely a number yeah for
sure you got a number yeah out of all
the things just say you don't like him
yeah just I just you just don't like him
that's fine how much how much for you to
beat up an old old guy
dude you want to say free no no no no
not free I'm not I'm not a psychopath
dude put me in the room with any old guy
uh he's getting his ass beat yeah I'll
[ __ ] a old dude up
for this right here these kitkats and
this Reese's I'll beat the [ __ ] out of
an old dude
I'll [ __ ] him up I'll [ __ ] old dude
right in his ass
I [ __ ] him in a [ __ ] [ __ ] ass up I
[ __ ] his I [ __ ] is I [ __ ] I [ __ ] his ass
up
I [ __ ] him in his ass up yeah
I'm [ __ ] in his ass
[Laughter]
cut the character's not gay sir it's
just
he just wants to beat up an old man all
right I got it okay all right yeah I'm
in there okay hey old guy take off your
pants I want to suck your [ __ ] old
dick and balls
I'm gonna fit your old dick and balls in
my throat
cut
come on man what what it's not even
close that line
what's the line
I'm gonna beat the [ __ ] out of you oh so
sorry okay okay I got it this time I got
it okay okay ready Down Speed okay and
action
don't put your [ __ ] [ __ ] through a
spin cycle
cut actually that works
wait no let me go to it again let me get
it okay okay all right
I'm gonna turn around and put my [ __ ]
[ __ ] on your penis
I'm gonna squeeze the head of your
[ __ ] dick
with my tight ass
until you come until you come
hey calm that's another fluid yeah yeah
yeah yeah we haven't touched on that one
yet so I'm glad we got around to that
one they call me to see us suck
because my [ __ ] is so tight it's
gonna see the senior soccer see her
my [ __ ] raps you like a coat and it's
just gonna squeeze you hey speaking of
which
um I mean speaking of nothing related
but Jack Harlow on SNL as you watch any
of it
speaking of sucking a dick for a million
dollars I I know I saw Clips but I
didn't it was pretty good yeah yeah no
he's a good actor he's definitely a good
actor yeah he's definitely funny he's
got a good sense of humor yeah
um
the sketches were like all right yeah
maybe you don't but it was good it was
good yeah I mean you don't
you don't expect the sketches to be good
yeah I mean yeah I don't know
was the last time SNL had a good bit
I mean I I actually like it's not a good
way you watch the uh the uh uh David
pumpkins or something like that do you
know what you want to talk about oh Tom
Hanks what is it with Tom Hanks yeah
yeah with Tom Hanks it's kind of like a
legendary sketch
and uh they did it for the first time
like six years ago and it's not like
this is an interesting one because it's
not like laugh out loud funny the first
time yeah but you're like the concept is
really funny sure and the delivery is
good and for some reason it just like
hits like it works
so they brought it back and I don't know
I was just I was like watching these
sketches just kind of like
is is this good I think it is good
no but it's a different kind of good so
how much to suck an old guy's dick
I'd much to suck Tom Hanks
I couldn't do that I must have beat up
Tom Hanks
that would be tough he's a good guy
he's a really good dude is he though
we don't know I mean he why did chat
turn out that way
hey man
that's a good point
I mean chuck could just be you know
check if we chat Chet could be just like
a like a soul got into his body yeah
yeah you know yeah they don't know what
happened yeah I think that's why they
probably put that soul in his body when
like Tom did his Illuminati yeah maybe
that's when he sold his soul
sacrifice one of his kids it was an
objectively good guy
um
I mean I've heard great things about Tom
Hanks
I mean working wise yeah like isn't he
kind of a legend around Hollywood
because he like stays on sets to yeah
yeah I've heard those yeah okay
to punch Tom Hanks just punch him yeah
punch him in the face
how much punch him clean in the jaw yeah
like Sucker Punch
see that's [ __ ] up
he doesn't even see it coming doesn't
know he's just standing there no see
he's standing there like like yeah he's
giving an autograph nah to like a sick
kid no you could murder someone if you
do that right
oh I'm okay it's just assuming you don't
kill them
Sucker Punch Tom Hanks
damn
how much did Jake make on the Ben askren
fight
because it's kind of like that yeah
yeah whatever Jake made on the Ben
askren fight that's how much I do it for
like 10 million or something I don't
know man that's like an irreversible
thing yeah if they catch me on camera
doing that I need I need dude I need I
need infinite money I need enough money
to like change my face structure to like
get plastic surgery yeah imagine imagine
that clip oh bro career people will be
like what is he
it's over for you dude no why did Noel
do that how do you sucker punch Thomas
so [ __ ] up
bruh that frame
oh my God Smith slap times five thousand
oh dude it'd be over
people imagine Tom Hanks is like like
you know on the stage of an awards show
and you walk on stage
and just deck drop him
I'd have to become a boxer
I'd have to so I'd have to become a
celebrity boxer anyone could take a
chance at me if I had that kind of power
yeah damn smoking Tom Hanks in front of
the world that's the saddest thought
yeah
you're an evil person
I don't know why I said that
it's so funny to just want to look at
Tom Hanks and be like how much does
Sucker Punch this [ __ ]
look can we play the other game we're
talking about like how much to suck a
dick nah nah nah
how much time I know how much how much
to lay this guy out
I like Tom Hanks